This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You probably have a favorite local TV ad. Something that's low budget with lots of graphics and terrible music. And it stars a fun, charismatic, in-your-face local business owner. Like New York's favorite stereo salesman, Crazy Eddie. It's a crazy Eddie Christmas in August. Audio, blowout blitz. Crazy Eddie's gonna save you a blizzard of bucks on stereo rec systems, comeback display as portable stereo.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。你可能有一则最喜欢的本地电视广告。那种预算很低、有很多图形和糟糕音乐的广告。而且它由一位有趣、有个人魅力、咄咄逼人的本地企业主主演。比如纽约最受欢迎的音响推销员疯狂埃迪。这是疯狂埃迪八月圣诞狂欢。音频，大甩卖突袭。疯狂埃迪将为你省下一大笔钱来购买音响录音系统，重返展示便携式音响。
Or the Martin Furniture Guy. Hi, Martin M. Dramat for the Martin Furniture Store. We owe this furniture business in Indiana. And our prices are out of this world. But if you grew up in Toronto in the 1980s, you probably know our local supermarket guy, Dave Nichol. By contrast, he was extremely low-key. That's producer and notable Canadian, Chris Barupé.
或者马丁家具店老板。嗨，我是马丁家具店的马丁·M·德拉马特。我们在印第安纳州经营这家家具生意。我们的价格简直不可思议。但如果你是在 20世纪 80 年代在多伦多长大，你可能知道我们的本地超市老板戴夫·尼科尔。相比之下，他极其低调。那是制作人兼知名的加拿大人克里斯·巴鲁佩。
Dave Nichol might be the most milk-toast guy to appear on television. He had these big wireframe glasses and this dome of brown hair and a prominent southern Ontario accent. In the past few weeks, there's been a lot of shouting about lower grocery prices. Recently, the major newspapers in Toronto and Ottawa compared prices at the major supermarkets. In both surveys, lobloas had the lowest prices.
戴夫·尼科尔可能是电视上出现过的最温吞的人。他戴着那种大号金属框眼镜，顶着一头棕色头发，带着浓重的主安大略口号。在过去几周里，关于杂货价格下降的争论很多。最近，多伦多和渥太华的主要报纸对主要超市的价格进行了比较。在两项调查中，罗布劳斯（Loblaw's）的价格都是最低的。
In the 80s, Nickel helped run a grocery store chain called lobloas, which makes me giggle just to sand. They had an inexpensive line of products they called the no name brand, which Nickel would sell in a series of sleep-inducing commercials. For example, these brand name pickles are almost twice as expensive as no name. Why is it then that in many supermarkets you find the national brand and one of the other jacuzzi? In these ads, Nickel would sit on a stool in front of a black background, and he would
在 80 年代，尼科尔曾帮助经营一家名为罗布劳斯的杂货连锁店，光是说出这个名字就让我咯咯笑。他们有一系列廉价产品，叫做无品牌（no name）系列，尼科尔会在一系列催眠般的商业广告中推销这些产品。例如，这些名牌泡菜的价格几乎是无品牌泡菜的两倍。为什么在许多超市里，你会发现国家品牌和另一个……在这些广告中，尼科尔会坐在黑色背景前的凳子上，他会
just talk. That was it. Though sometimes for added excitement, he'd include his dog in the ad. This is not ET. This is Georgie Girl, and she's a French bulldog. These discount ads were part of a strategy. The ads were notably plain, just like the products, because no name had basically no package design. If you bought no name cookies, here's what you get.
只是说话。就是这样。不过有时为了增加刺激性，他会把他的狗带进广告里。这不是 E.T.。这是乔治吉尔，它是一只法国斗牛犬。这些折扣广告是策略的一部分。这些广告非常朴素，就像产品一样，因为无品牌基本上没有包装设计。如果你买无品牌饼干，你会得到以下东西。
A box was some cookies inside. Which, you know, I guess that's what you always get. But in this case, the box had a plain background with black text that said chocolate chip cookies. And that was it. There was no name peanut butter, no name detergent, no name orange juice, all of it was dirt cheap. And LaBlaz wasn't unique. It was one of the many supermarket chains across North America that was riding a generic product craze in the late 70s and the early 80s. But LaBlaz took it further than anyone. Their generic marketing plan changed the way we eat and shop. And ironically, their strategy to go brandless became one of the most successful branding campaigns.
一个里面装着饼干的盒子。你知道的，我想你总是能得到这个。但在这个例子中，盒子有一个简单的背景和黑色的文字，上面写着巧克力豆饼干。就是这样。有无品牌花生酱、无品牌洗涤剂、无品牌橙汁，所有这些都便宜得要命。罗布劳斯并不是独一无二的。它是北美众多超市连锁店之一，在 70 年代末和 80 年代初掀起了一股非品牌产品热潮。但罗布劳斯比任何人都走得更远。他们的非品牌营销计划改变了我们吃东西和购物的方式。具有讽刺意味的是，他们去品牌化的策略成为了最成功的品牌营销活动之一。
About a hundred years ago, we really didn't have supermarkets. If you went shopping, you had to go to the green grocer, and the butcher, and then someone delivered your milk, and it was so, so time consuming. But in 1916, Clarence Saunders opened a store in Tennessee called Piggly Wiggly, which was the first place with self-service groceries, rows and rows of products that you could pick out yourself. Soon, America was overrun with grocery stores. After World War II, these stores were filled
大约一百年前，我们真的没有超市。如果你去购物，你必须去绿色杂货店、肉铺，然后有人把牛奶送到你家，这太、太耗时了。但在 1916 年，克拉伦斯·桑德斯在田纳西州开了一家名为皮格利·威格利（Piggly Wiggly）的商店，这是第一个提供自助杂货的地方，一排排你可以自己挑选的产品。不久，美国到处都是杂货店。二战后，这些商店挤满了
with famous national brands. A couple of factors helped the big brands take over, like the new Interstate Highway system, which made it easy to deliver goods. And of course, the rise of television. When you have your way, you start every day. With shallows, the Red Magic. Think about the cereal aisle, soft drinks, cleaning the church and proctor and gamble, Nabisco, general foods. Those were the biggest advertisers in the post-war era.
著名的国家品牌。几个因素帮助大品牌接管了市场，比如新的州际公路系统，这使得运送货物变得容易。当然，还有电视的兴起。当你随心所欲时，你每一天都从……开始。想想谷物货架、软饮料、清洁剂，宝洁、纳贝斯克、通用食品。这些是战后时代最大的广告商。
They really are the big spenders and the big spenders were the brands advertisers in the post-war era. They really are the big spenders and the big spenders were the brand's most people wanted. This is my favorite marketer, Terry O'Reilly. And I am the host of Under the Influence, which is a CBC radio show and podcast, and I am a 40-year ad man. O'Reilly says, back at the advent of TV, telling people about your new product was pretty easy.
他们真的是挥金如土的人，而挥金如土的人是战后时代品牌广告商的目标。他们真的是挥金如土的人，而挥金如土的人是大多数人想要的品牌。这是我最喜欢的营销人员泰瑞·奥赖利。我是《潜移默化》（Under the Influence）的主持人，这是一档 CBC 广播节目和播客，我是一个有 40 年经验的广告人。奥赖利说，早在电视刚出现时，向人们介绍你的新产品相当容易。
If you had the money to buy commercials on the biggest shows. It was a time when you could buy, you had Sullivan show and Bonanza and maybe Gunsmoke back in the 60s and by buying just those three programs, you would be reaching 80% of America in Canada. The name brands became dominant. They were most of what people bought at grocery stores in North America. To fill out the shelves, supermarkets would make their own store brand products too. Often, these look kind of like the big brands, with the name of the supermarket slapped
如果你有钱在最大的节目上买广告。那是一个你可以购买的时代，你有沙利文秀、大班车（Bonanza），可能还有 60 年代的荒野大镖客（Gunsmoke），只要买下这三个节目，你就能触及美国和加拿大 80% 的受众。名牌占据了主导地位。它们是北美人们在杂货店里买得最多的东西。为了填满货架，超市也会制作自己的商店品牌产品。通常，这些看起来有点像大品牌，超市的名字被印在
on the side of the box. Store brands were mostly popular with people who wanted a low budget alternative to the name brand stuff. They wanted to buy something that was, you know, not as good, but not as expensive. This is Stephen Hoek. He's an emeritus marketing professor at the Wharton School. And he says store brands weren't always the highest quality, but many of them were close enough to the name brands, mainly because a lot of grocery store products
盒子的侧面。商店品牌主要受那些想要购买预算较低的名牌替代品的人欢迎。他们想买一些你知道的、没那么好但也没那么贵的东西。这是斯蒂芬·霍克。他是沃顿商学院的荣誉市场营销教授。他说，商店品牌并不总是质量最高的，但其中许多与大品牌相当接近，主要是因为很多杂货店的产品
are easy to make. Take, for example, cornflakes. What do you need? You need some machine that can spit out corn batter and into some machine that nukes it and all of a sudden it's a cornflake. So there's always a bunch of manufacturers that can do it.
很容易制作。以玉米片为例。你需要什么？你需要一台能吐出玉米面糊的机器，进入一台能用微波加热它的机器，突然之间它就成了玉米片。所以总有一群制造商能做到这一点。
And you know, for instance, shampoo. Anybody can make shampoo. You know, anybody can make shampoo all you need is a bathtub and some chemicals and some bottles. But the store brands weren't big sellers until they received a boost in the late 1970s. After the oil crisis, the global economy went into a recession. Unemployment hit 11 percent and suddenly middle class families didn't have money for name brands like Coke or Kellogg's. Consumers want a cheaper food. In response, there was a new demand for low-cost store brands.
你知道的，比如洗发水。任何人都可以做洗发水。你知道的，任何人都可以做洗发水，你只需要一个浴缸、一些化学品和一些瓶子。但商店品牌的销量一直不高，直到在 20 世纪 70 年代末得到了推动。石油危机后，全球经济陷入衰退。失业率达到 11%，突然之间，中产阶级家庭没有钱购买可口可乐或家乐氏等名牌产品。消费者想要更便宜的食物。作为回应，对低成本商店品牌有了新的需求。
One chain in France called Carifor was developing one of these discount brands when they had this idea. Instead of using bright colors or putting their name on the box or using slogans, you know, branding, their products would be brand less, just the name of the food and black text on a white background. This minimalist design was a brilliant marketing tool. It delivered the message that, this is cheap. We're cutting costs and we are passing the savings down to you. This is bare bones and you're having a hard time coping here because maybe you're unemployed or whatever.
法国的一家连锁店家乐福（Carrefour）在开发这些折扣品牌时有了这个想法。他们不用鲜艳的颜色，不用把名字印在盒子上，也不用口号——你知道的，也就是不做品牌推广，他们的产品将是没有品牌的，只有食物名称和白底黑字。这种极简主义设计是一个绝妙的营销工具。它传递的信息是：这很便宜。我们在削减成本，并将节省下来的钱转让给你们。这是最基础的东西，你在这里过得很艰难，因为你可能失业了什么的。
And so here is a way that you can substitute away from a more expensive product and still satisfy your kids when they wake up in the morning. They want some cereal for breakfast. In 1976, Cara for launched the new product line, which they called Le Proudouille Libra, which means in English, free products, which, you know, they weren't actually free, but these products were 20-30% cheaper than everything else at the store. And it worked. Soon, the Proudouille Libra were a hit. Versus story executives from North America were actually flying to Europe just to check
所以这里有一种方法，你可以用它来替代更昂贵的产品，并且在你的孩子早上醒来时仍然能满足他们。他们早餐想吃麦片。1976 年，家乐福推出了这个新产品线，他们将其命名为 Le Produit Libre，在英文中意为“自由产品”，你知道的，它们其实并不是免费的，但这些产品的价格比店里的其他所有东西便宜 20-30%。它奏效了。很快，Produit Libre 获得了巨大成功。北美各地的商店高管甚至飞往欧洲考察
out Kerafore and see what the hype was about. Soon, the Proudwe Libra idea was being copied by everybody. Stephen Hoek says, at first, it was a bit of a shock. I just had moved to Chicago and the big grocery chain there was called Jewel. I remember going to the store and all of a sudden, I saw these black and white packages. It was black type on a white package for every single one of those things. So it said napkins and that was it. It's like a minimalist heaven. Chain stores like Jewel, in Chicago, and Ralph's in California were packaging and selling their own generic products. In many stores, the generic products were given a separate aisle. This helped promote their novelty,
家乐福，看看有什么好炒作的。很快，Produit Libre 的理念就被所有人效仿了。斯蒂芬·霍克说，起初，这有点令人震惊。我刚搬到芝加哥，那里的大型连锁超市叫 Jewel。我记得去商店，突然我看到了这些黑白包装。每一样东西都是白底黑字。所以上面写着餐巾纸，仅此而已。这就像是一个极简主义的天堂。像芝加哥的 Jewel 和加利福尼亚的 Ralph's 这样的连锁店都在包装和销售他们自己的无品牌产品。在许多商店里，无品牌产品被安排在单独的过道里。这有助于推广它们的新颖性，
but it also prevented shoppers from comparing them side-by-side with the nicer-looking brand name products. But one Canadian grocery store took this idea of generic branding to a whole new extreme. And the catalyst was the man a lot of Canadians knew from local TV ads, the president of LaBla's supermarkets, Dave Nichol. Dave Nichol wasn't born rich, but he was a man of refined tastes. He went to Harvard Law School, he loved to fly first class, and he personally knew the chefs
但也阻止了购物者将它们与外表更美观的名牌产品进行并排比较。但加拿大的一家杂货店将这种无品牌概念推向了一个全新的极端。而催化剂是一个许多加拿大人从当地电视广告中认识的人，罗布劳斯超市的总裁戴夫·尼科尔。戴夫·尼科尔并非出生于富裕家庭，但他是个品味高雅的人。他上过哈佛法学院，喜欢坐头等舱，并且个人认识
at many of the three star restaurants in Europe. Dave Nichol was friends with Galen Weston, who was from one of the richest families in Canada. The Weston's owned law laws, and they tapped Dave Nichol to help run the company, even though he had no experience running a supermarket. At the time, law laws was in a really bad place. They were trailing way behind their competitor, the grocery chain, Dominion.
欧洲许多三星级餐厅的主厨。戴夫·尼科尔是加伦·韦斯特的朋友，加伦·韦斯特来自加拿大最富有的家族之一。韦斯特家族拥有罗布劳斯，他们挑选戴夫·尼科尔来帮助管理公司，尽管他没有任何经营超市的经验。当时，罗布劳斯处境非常糟糕。他们的业绩远远落后于竞争对手杂货连锁店多明尼恩（Dominion）。
Law laws was closing stores, laying off workers. The only thing Loblaws had going for it was a celebrity pitchman, a William Shatter. Hey, right now, Loblaws is having a huge frozen food sale. It's frozen vegetables, frozen meat on trays, frozen concentrated juices, ice cream. If it's frozen, you can save plenty. Don't get left out on the cool. Nichol saw the Los Ails and the stores closing and he decided we need to change things up.
罗布劳斯在关闭商店、解雇工人。罗布劳斯唯一拿得出手的是一个名人代言人威廉·夏特纳。嘿，现在罗布劳斯正在举行巨大的冷冻食品大甩卖。有冷冻蔬菜、托盘装冷冻肉、冷冻浓缩果汁、冰淇淋。如果是冷冻的，你可以省下一大笔钱。不要被冷落。尼科尔看到了亏损和不断关闭的商店，他决定我们需要改变现状。
So La Blas took care of for his discount branding idea and they ran with it. They launched no name. It was just like the black and white generics you could find in America and Europe. But the La Blas products had one big design flourish. He hired a great designer named Don Watt, who just chose yellow, stark banana yellow, and just big chunky, helvetica type. Yellow feels like a discount color. I guess like it's
所以罗布劳斯采纳了家乐福的折扣品牌理念并将其发扬光大。他们推出了无品牌（no name）。它就像你在美国和欧洲能找到的黑白无品牌产品一样。但罗布劳斯的商品有一个重大的设计特色。他雇了一位名叫唐·沃特的伟大设计师，他只选择了黄色，刺眼的香蕉黄，以及大而粗壮的 Helvetica 字体。黄色感觉像是一种折扣颜色。我想就像它的
cousin orange. And I think Don Watt really chose yellow because it was a color least used by big brands. It was almost like Orwellian, no romance in it. The Nickel didn't just launch the product line. He made it an entire store. The worst performing law-blow stores were shut down and rebranded as no frills. These new stores carried very few name brands. It was dominated by no name products. To make this painfully clear, the entire store was painted black and bright yellow. The first no frills opened in Toronto in 1978.
表亲橙色一样。我认为唐·沃特选择黄色是因为它是大品牌最少使用的颜色。它几乎带有奥威尔式的色彩，没有任何浪漫色彩。尼科尔不只是推出了产品线。他把它变成了一家整店。表现最差的罗布劳斯门店被关闭并重新命名为无修饰（no frills）。这些新店极少出售名牌商品。这里以无品牌产品为主。为了痛苦地表明这一点，整家店被漆成黑色和亮黄色。第一家无修饰门店于 1978 年在多伦多开业。
Dave Nichol was actually doing a TV interview when he found out what certain customers thought about the color scheme. What do you think of the problem, man? The color outside is loasy. What do you think the problem is? The color outside is loasy. What do you think about the price to check the price? No, I haven't checked the price yet. It was a real bargain-bent experience.
戴夫·尼科尔实际上是在接受电视采访时发现某些顾客对配色方案的看法的。你觉得这个有什么问题，老兄？外面的颜色太烂了。你觉得问题出在哪里？外面的颜色太烂了。你觉得价格怎么样，你看过价格吗？不，我还没看过价格。这是一次真正的淘宝体验。
People had to bag their own groceries. And while the products were cheaper, some customers expressed ambivalence about the new store. There's no butcher, no bakery, no frozen food, no air conditioning, no fancy displays, and not even much choice of products. But what it does have is customer. How do you like packing, having to pack your own bag?
人们不得不自己打包杂货。虽然产品更便宜，但一些顾客对这家新店表现出矛盾的心理。这里没有肉铺、没有面包店、没有冷冻食品、没有空调、没有花哨的陈列，甚至没有多少产品选择。但它确实有的是顾客。你觉得打包怎么样，不得不自己打包？
Don't like it. All right, I didn't want to, was to have a bag. I'll bring my own next time. You'd come back next time? Well, of course. When the news store opened, Dave Nicholl had replaced William Shatner as the face of the company. And he launched the bland new ad campaign,
不喜欢。好吧，我不想，本想有个袋子。我下次自己带。你下次还会来吗？嗯，当然。新店开业时，戴夫·尼科尔取代了威廉·夏特纳成为公司的代言人。他发起了一场全新的广告活动，
which sent a pretty clear message about what Law Bloss was offering. You don't have to pay for the mass advertising and all the design work and all the marketing that goes on behind the jar of jam. All you should be paying for is the jam. And Nick will call that brand tax. The news doors were a success.
这传递了一个非常明确的信息，关于罗布劳斯在提供什么。你不必为大众广告、所有的设计工作以及果酱罐背后进行的所有营销买单。你唯一应该支付的只有果酱的钱。尼科尔称之为品牌税。新店取得了成功。
It turns out a lot of consumers didn't want to pay the brand tax. They didn't want the bells and whistles. And in America, by the early 1980s, billions of dollars in generic products were being sold every year. As they got more popular, it's clear the generic products were becoming exactly the thing they were supposed to be rebelling against. A no-name brand is a brand. Surprise! It is presented to the public as a non-brand, meaning a viable choice to big name brands. But in itself, a generic product is a brand. You're appealing to people or to shoppers who think that people who do pay for big brands
事实证明，许多消费者不想支付品牌税。他们不需要花里胡哨的东西。在美国，到 20 世纪 80 年代初，每年都有价值数十亿美元的无品牌产品售出。随着它们越来越受欢迎，很明显，无品牌产品正在变成它们本应反抗的东西。无品牌也是一个品牌。惊喜！它作为一个非品牌呈现在公众面前，意味着它是大名牌的一个可行选择。但就其本身而言，无品牌产品就是一个品牌。你在吸引那些认为购买大品牌的人
are foolish, when they could have the same thing and just not pay for the advertising, not pay for the fancy label. The generic brand was so powerful by the early 80s, it was showing up on the fringes of pop culture in the sci-fi movie repo man it was used as this great visual joke about how the world was becoming more and more conformist in the movie Emilio Estevez works in a grocery store that is slowly crushing his soul and only stocks generic products in One scene Estevez eats out of a can, simply labeled food. Put it on a plate, son. You'll enjoy it, your wife.
是愚蠢的购物者，因为他们本可以买到同样的东西，却不用为广告买单，不用为花哨的标签买单。到 80 年代初，无品牌的影响力如此之大，以至于它出现在流行文化的边缘，在科幻电影《报复者》（Repo Man）中，它被用作一个伟大的视觉笑话，讽刺世界变得越来越墨守成规。在电影中，埃米利奥·埃斯特维兹在一家杂货店工作，这家店慢慢地粉碎了他的灵魂，只进货无品牌产品。在一个场景中，埃斯特维兹从一个只简单贴着“食物”标签的罐头里吃东西。把它放在盘子里，孩子。你会喜欢的，你的妻子。
You'll enjoy it anymore, mom. Mmm, mmm, mmm. This is swell. Generic products were featured in a music video by the band's suicidal tendencies, and there was a whole series of books, Freelidly called No Freels Books. I thought of it as a satire on publishing, if you could have No Freels' corn flakes,
你不会再喜欢了，妈妈。嗯，嗯，嗯。这太棒了。无品牌产品在乐队“自杀倾向”（Suicidal Tendencies）的音乐录影带中亮相，并且还有一整套名为“无修饰书籍”（No Frills Books）的书籍。我把它当作对出版业的一种讽刺，如果你可以有“无修饰玉米片”，
why couldn't you have a No Freels romance? This is Terry Bisson, who edited the series, which was not affiliated in any way with the No Freels' store, but the cover was black and white to make it look like those generic grocery products. It's a No Frills book mystery and then it says, complete with everything. Detective, telephone, mysterious woman corpses, money, rain. And the science fiction is complete with everything. Aliens, giant ants, space cadets, robots, one plucky girl.
为什么你不能有“无修饰言情小说”呢？这是泰瑞·比森，他是该系列的编辑，该系列与无修饰商店没有任何附属关系，但封面是黑白的，使其看起来像那些无品牌的杂货产品。这是一本无修饰书籍悬念小说，然后上面写着，应有尽有。侦探、电话、神秘女人尸体、金钱、雨。而科幻小说则是应有尽有。外星人、巨型蚂蚁、太空学员、机器人、一个勇敢的女孩。
The No Real Series got positive reviews, including a feature in the New York Times book section. They got this enormous press attention because every newspaper in the country has, in those days, had a book editor or somebody that was supposed to look out for stuff. Well, they all thought it was a hoot. There was also a script for a no frills movie, which never got produced because, you know, you can only take this joke so far. In the early 80s, generics were a phenomenon, but the novelty couldn't last. And while the branding was clever, it couldn't hide the fact that some generic products,
“无修饰”系列获得了好评，包括《纽约时报》书评专栏的专题报道。他们获得了巨大的媒体关注，因为那时的全国每家报纸都有一个图书编辑或某个负责留意这类东西的人。好吧，他们都觉得这很有趣。还有一个“无修饰”电影的剧本，但从未制作出来，因为你知道的，这个笑话只能开到这种程度。在 80 年代初，无品牌是一种现象，但这种新奇感无法持久。虽然品牌战略很聪明，但它掩盖不了一个事实，即一些无品牌产品，
well, they just weren't very good. The toilet paper, I mean, it just wasn't just in work, dude, it's job, you know? Steven Hoke says this happened with a lot of generic products. I tried a few things and they really just weren't, it wasn't worth it. And he wasn't alone in that opinion. Jim White was an executive at Lawbloss. On April 4th, 1984, I joined Dave Nichol. And Dave was always going on TV, teaching no-name products.
嗯，它们的质量实在算不上好。卫生纸，我的意思是，它就是不好用，老兄，它没做好它的工作，你知道吗？斯蒂芬·霍克说很多无品牌产品都发生过这种情况。我尝试了一些东西，它们确实不行，不值得。持有这种观点的不止他一个人。吉姆·怀特是罗布劳斯的一位高管。1984 年 4 月 4 日，我加入了戴夫·尼科尔。戴夫总是上电视，宣传无品牌产品。
He was pitching the yellow and black product line, all of them being inferior to the National Brands and their only benefit was that they were cheaper than the national brand. It took me a couple of months to figure out that no name was no bueno. To bring down the price for generics, some sort of markets were cutting corners. Shoppers were finding cans full of bruised peaches in the generic section. I think nothing will kill a product faster than good marketing. So if you've got great marketing on your generic brands and then people are drawn to try it and it tastes terrible,
他在推销黄色和黑色的产品线，所有这些产品都比国家品牌劣质，它们唯一的优点是比国家品牌便宜。我花了几个月时间才弄明白，无品牌其实一点也不好（no bueno）。为了降低无品牌的售价，一些超市在偷工减料。购物者在无品牌专区发现了装满擦伤桃子的罐头。我认为没有什么能比糟糕的营销更快地毁掉一个产品了。所以如果你的无品牌产品有伟大的营销，然后人们被吸引去尝试，结果味道极差，
nothing will kill a product faster than that. Now to be clear, not all generic products were bad. Many of the generics were the same product as the brand names, just in different packaging. Loblaws actually used taste tests for their no-name products, but a couple of low-quality generics spoiled the whole bunch for a lot of customers. The recession ended,
没有什么能比这更快地毁掉一个产品了。需要明确的是，并非所有无品牌产品都很糟糕。许多无品牌产品与大品牌是同一款产品，只是换了不同的包装。罗布劳斯实际上对他们的无品牌产品进行了品尝测试，但少数低质量的无品牌产品让许多顾客对整个系列都失去了信心。经济衰退结束了，
and when the unemployment rate dropped, people went right back to the brand names. In a lot of ways, generic branding was out of step with the culture of the 1980s. That was really the era of over-exuberance and yuppiness and BMWs and big salaries and fancy clothes and electronics. I think that era for whatever reason in the 80s was about spending money. With consumerism dominating culture, buying generics became embarrassing.
当失业率下降时，人们又回到了名牌产品上。在很多方面，无品牌营销与 20 世纪 80 年代的文化格格不入。那真的是一个过度亢奋、雅皮士、宝马、高薪、华丽衣服和电子产品的时代。我认为那个时代的 80 年代无论出于什么原因，都是关于花钱的。随着消费主义主导文化，购买无品牌产品变成了一件令人尴尬的事情。
Lots of American supermarkets gave up on the generic experiment, but in Canada, law laws didn't get rid of no name. They just moved it lower down the shelf, and they created a second product to attract the yuppies. Here's Jim White again. I think what in my own mind was, I wanted to go after the more affluent shopper. We should create the first premium private label program in North America. It didn't exist.
许多美国超市放弃了无品牌实验，但在加拿大，罗布劳斯并没有抛弃无品牌。他们只是把它移到了货架更低的位置，并创造了第二个产品来吸引雅皮士。再次请出吉姆·怀特。我想我当时的想法是，我想去争取更富裕的购物者。我们应该在北美创造第一个高端自有品牌计划。它并不存在。
It only existed in my head. So premium private label is another term for a nicer quality store brand. Basically, Loblaws wanted to make a storebrand that was affordable, but felt luxurious. Jim White remembers talking about it with his boss, Dave Nichol. He said, what do you think we should call it? And this guy Dave had a very large ego. He was very pleased with himself. And knowing that, I simply said to him, I think we should call it President's Choice. And then he rose and he said, yes, do it! The packages for President's Choice were definitely nicer to look at. They were also designed by
它只存在于我的脑海中。因此，高端自有品牌是更优质的商店品牌的另一个术语。基本上，罗布劳斯想要制造一种负担得起但感觉奢华的商店品牌。吉姆·怀特回忆起与他的老板戴夫·尼科尔谈论此事的情景。他说，你觉得我们应该叫它什么？这个叫戴夫的家伙有着非常强烈的自我意识。他对自己的表现非常满意。明知这一点，我只是对他说，我想我们应该叫它“总统的选择”（President's Choice）。然后他站起来说，是的，干吧！“总统的选择”的包装绝对更赏心悦目。它们也是由
Don Wad and his team, and they used lots of color. They had these pictures on the front that resembled the Photos in Gourmet magazine. Oh, and the logo was the words President's Choice in Dave Nichols handwriting. The products even had fancy names. They didn't carry macaroni and cheese. They had white cheddar deluxe macaroni and cheese. That's deluxe with an E. Their Oreo imitator was called Lucullin Delights, named after the Heedness Roman General Lucullus. They eventually had to change the name on that one because nobody understood the reference.
唐·沃特和他的团队设计的，并且他们使用了大量的颜色。他们的正面印有类似于《美食》杂志上照片的图片。哦，标志是戴夫·尼科尔亲笔书写的“总统的选择”几个字。这些产品甚至有 fancy 的名字。它们卖的不是通心粉和奶酪。它们有白切达豪华通心粉和奶酪（white cheddar deluxe macaroni and cheese）。那个 deluxe 带有一个字母 E。他们的奥利奥仿制品被称为 Lucullan Delights，以追求享乐的罗马将军卢库卢斯命名。他们最终不得不更改那个产品的名字，因为没有人理解这个典故。
Dave Nichol was still doing TV ads and talking directly to customers. But now, instead of focusing exclusively on rock bottom prices, Nichol also talked about his world travels in search of gourmet flavors. Every year I take two or three extended trips, let's say to Singapore or Taballi, and usually because of the length of the distances we lay over in Hong Kong. And so I've spent a lot of time in the restaurants of Hong Kong, and I think one of the flavors
戴夫·尼科尔仍在做电视广告，并直接与顾客对话。但现在，尼科尔不再只专注于最低价格，还谈到了他为了寻找美食风味而进行的环球旅行。每年我都会进行两三次长途旅行，比如说去新加坡或巴厘岛，通常因为距离太远，我们会在香港转机。所以我花了很多时间在香港的餐厅里，我认为其中一种风味
that has always intrigued me. Lobos was spending a lot of money on research and development so that their new food would live up to all these fancy product names. Jim White even spent months trying to make the perfect chocolate chip cookie. It took nine months just to make the chocolate. And this new super cookie would be called the decadent. And then we launched it and you know, history was made. It seems so odd to say that in hindsight,
一直让我着迷。罗布劳斯在研发上投入了大量资金，以便他们的新食品能够对得起所有这些花哨的产品名称。吉姆·怀特甚至花了几个月的时间来制作完美的巧克力豆曲奇。光是制作巧克力就花了九个月。这种超级曲奇将被命名为“沉沦”（The Decadent）。然后我们推出了它，你知道的，历史被创造了。回想起来，说这样的话似乎很奇怪，
that a cookie could be so powerful in the marketing of an entire grocery chain. But it happened. So if you tasted that cookie at that time, it was mind-blowing. The decadent quickly became a best seller. And soon, Dave Nicholene's Law Bloss team were hired to develop new fancy
一块曲奇居然能在整个杂货连锁店的营销中发挥如此巨大的威力。但它确实发生了。所以如果你当时尝过那块曲奇，它会让你大开眼界。“沉沦”迅速成为畅销书。不久，戴夫·尼科尔和他的罗布劳斯团队被雇佣为全美各大超市开发新的 fancy
store brands for big supermarkets across America. He was eventually revered across North America as a great grocery merchandiser at marketer because even Sam Walton hired Dave Nichol to come and consult on his private label, Grans. Even a company as big as Wal-Mart was trying to pick Dave Nichols' mind at that stage. Walmart rolled out its own version of President's Choice called Sam's Choice. And after leaving Loblaws, Jim White helped create premium private labels all over the world.
商店品牌。他最终在整个北美被尊崇为伟大的杂货商人和营销人员，因为连山姆·沃尔顿都雇用戴夫·尼科尔来就他的自有品牌（Grans应为Brands）提供咨询。甚至像沃尔玛这样大的公司在那时也试图揣摩戴夫·尼科尔的想法。沃尔玛推出了自己的“总统的选择”版本，名为“山姆的选择”（Sam's Choice）。离开罗布劳斯后，吉姆·怀特帮助在世界各地创建了高端自有品牌。
Wegmans and Walmart and Safeway and bonds and stop and shop, finest and Fred Meyer and Myers, a creative products for all of them. Today, one in four products sold in American supermarkets are store brand. And that's partly because more of those store brands follow the president's choice model. These products all have colorful packages and aspirational names like signature farms or market cafe. They look fancier even if they cost less than the national brands. The message for generic products used to be, this product is just good enough.
韦格曼斯（Wegmans）、沃尔玛、西夫韦（Safeway）、邦兹（Vons）、停止与购物（Stop & Shop）、芬尼斯（Finast）和弗雷德·迈尔（Fred Meyer）以及迈尔（Meijer），为所有这些公司创造产品。如今，美国超市销售的产品中，有四分之一是商店品牌。部分原因是更多的商店品牌遵循了“总统的选择”模式。这些产品都有色彩缤纷的包装和富有抱负的名字，如 Signature Farms 或 Market Café。即使它们比国家品牌便宜，它们看起来也更高级。无品牌产品过去传达的信息是：这款产品刚刚好。
Now the message is, you were a discerning shopper who's looking for a more curated product experience. Entire supermarkets like Trader Joe's are built around this principle here to Steven Hook. If you kind of look at store brands versus national brands, you know, store brands are given the national brands in most product categories are real run for their money. And the reason why is because they're just about as good. The minimal generic products, you know, the ones that just say cereal on the outside and
现在传达的信息是：你是一个有眼光的购物者，正在寻找更精致的产品体验。像 Trader Joe's 这样的整个超市都是围绕这个原则建立的，请听斯蒂芬·霍克的观点。如果你看一下商店品牌与国家品牌，你知道的，在大多数产品类别中，商店品牌给国家品牌带来了真正的激烈竞争。原因在于它们几乎一样好。极简主义的无品牌产品，你知道的，外面只写着“麦片”和
black text, those are a lot harder to find in America now. But in Canada, those products are still going strong. In 2009, during the last big recession, no name had an upswing in sales. And at the beginning of the pandemic, there were lines down the block outside of no-feril stores in Toronto. Because when the economy is bad, that's when more people turn to a store like no-ferils. I mean, imagine right now how appealing that pitch is to people who have lost their jobs, the venacity salary cuts as everybody self isolates.
黑色文字的那种，现在在美国很难找到了。但在加拿大，这些产品依然强劲。2009 年，在上一次经济大衰退期间，无品牌的销量有所上升。在大流行开始时，多伦多无修饰商店门外排起了长队。因为当经济不景气时，这正是更多人转向无修饰这样的商店的时候。我的意思是，想象一下现在这种推销对那些失去工作、面临减薪、所有人都在自我隔离的人有多大吸引力。
Even now that pitch is resident. Jim White said to me, his company started with no name, but it graduated to President's Choice. And that makes sense. Generic brands and nicer private labels, they've always been pitched as opposite. When you think about it, they're really selling you the same thing.
即使在现在，这种推销也很有共鸣。吉姆·怀特对我说，他的公司以无品牌起家，但后来升级到了“总统的选择”。这很合理。无品牌和更优质的自有品牌，它们一直被宣传为对立的。当你仔细想想，它们卖的其实是同一样东西。
Both of them are saying, you, you aren't swayed by brand name marketing. You're too smart for that. And really, that's one of the oldest marketing tricks in the book. Now the price of bread in Canada affects the US presidential election after this. Okay, so I'm here with Chris Baroube, Hey, Gris. Hey, how's it going, Roman? I'm doing pretty well. We're under blankets or in closets talking to each other. We are. It is, there's always a distance between us,
它们都在说：你，你不会被名牌营销所左右。你太聪明了，不会上当。真的，这是书中最古老的营销把手之一。接下来我们将探讨加拿大面包价格如何影响美国总统大选。好了，我和克里斯·巴鲁佩在这里，嘿，格里斯。嘿，最近怎么样，罗曼？我挺好的。我们在毛毯下或衣橱里互相交谈。我们是这样的。确实，我们之间总是有距离，
but it's more absurd when I see you under the blanket and you see me in front of all of my shirts. Exactly. Exactly. So you have a little addition to this story. So let's let's talk about them. I do. So since I I've been reporting this story for a while and since I started no frills and wobblers have actually been in the news quite a bit. So I wanted to do kind of a round up of all of the Canadian grocery store news that has happened since I started working on this story. And stay with us because it trust me, it gets really exciting. But first things first, Roman, I sent you a clip from the episode and I think we need to talk about it before we do anything
但当我看到你躲在毛毯下，而你看到我站在我所有的衬衫前面时，这就更荒谬了。完全正确。完全正确。所以你对这个故事有一个小小的补充。所以让我们来谈谈它们。我有。自从我报道这个故事一段时间以来，而且自从我开始以来，无修饰和罗布劳斯实际上已经出现在很多新闻中。所以我想要总结一下自从我开始做这个故事以来发生的所有加拿大杂货店新闻。请继续收听，因为相信我，这真的非常令人兴奋。但首先第一件事，罗曼，我给你发了这一集的一个片段，我觉得在我们做其他事情之前我们需要讨论一下。
else. So could you play the clip? Got it. Okay. Here we go. He hired a great designer named Don Watt who just chose yellow, stark banana yellow, and just big chunky, he'll medic a type. Yellow feels like a discount color. I guess like it's cousin orange. Roman, when I was talking to Terry O'Reilly, he's a very persuasive man.
所以你能播放一下这个片段吗？好的。好的。我们开始吧。他雇了一位名叫唐·沃特的伟大设计师，他只选择了黄色，刺眼的香蕉黄，以及大而粗壮的 Helvetica 字体。黄色感觉像是一种折扣颜色。我想就像它的表亲橙色一样。罗曼，当我与泰瑞·奥赖利交谈时，他是一个非常有说服力的人。
And when he said black and yellow feels like a discount color scheme, at first I was like, oh yeah, he's totally right. And then it occurred to me that is also the color scheme of the show 99% visible. It's no problem. I sort of think of it that we're, we're black with yellow. So, you know, so that we, we was light edge. That feels right. I mean, this actually brings me into the first news item
当他说黑黄相间感觉像是一种折扣配色方案时，起初我觉得，哦，是的，他完全说得对。然后我突然想到，这也是节目 99% Invisible 的配色方案。没问题。我有点认为我们是，我们是带着黄色的黑色，所以，你知道，所以我们，我们有点边缘。这感觉很对。我的意思是，这实际上让我想到了关于无修饰的第一个新闻。去年，无修饰推出了这个巨大的广告活动。
about no frills. Last year, no frills launched this huge ad campaign. So for a brief time, that bright banana yellow and the black heavettica font basically took over the city of Toronto. So if you were walking around, you would see it everywhere. So I've sent you a couple of photos. I want you to open up the first one. Okay. This is great. So this is like an old building has a sort of man-served roof.
所以在很长一段时间里，那明亮的香蕉黄和黑色的 Helvetica 字体基本上占领了多伦多市。所以如果你到处走走，你会到处看到它。所以我给你发了几张照片。我想让你打开第一张。好的。这太棒了。所以这就像是一座老建筑，有一种类似曼萨ard（mansard）风格的屋顶。
Like a single section of the old building is just painted yellow. It says the word building on it. Yeah. So for a while, this was everywhere. This was a blanket campaign to get people aware of no frills. So I've sent you another one. Actually, if you want to open up the second one, I describe that too. This is also like a takeoff of the no name label and it says no name and it says it's a big yellow wall and it says subway platform with assorted commuters and trains. So this was the strategy of the ad campaign they put out last year was to basically embrace the irony. They also watched this like ironic Twitter campaign. At one point, they live tweeted the golden globes, and one of the tweets from that was an actor has won an award like they really have doubled down on kind of the ironic elements of their brand. Right. Right. You know, some people found
老建筑的一个部分被刷成了黄色。上面写着“建筑”这个词。是的。所以有一段时间，这无处不在。这是一场让人们了解无修饰的全方位宣传活动。所以我给你发了另一张。实际上，如果你想打开第二张，我也描述一下。这也是对无品牌标签的一种模仿，它上面写着无品牌，它说这是一堵巨大的黄色墙壁，上面写着带有形形色色的通勤者和火车的地铁站台。所以这就是他们去年推出的广告活动的策略，基本上是拥抱这种讽刺。他们还开展了一场讽刺性的推特活动。有一度，他们对金球奖进行了实时推特直播，其中一条推特说某个演员获得了奖项，他们真的在品牌中加倍投入了讽刺元素。对的。对的。你知道，有些人发现
that really delightful. Like I don't know, how do you feel seeing all of that? I think it's great. It's really like, you know, it taps into nostalgia, which I'm always a little bit nervous about. But I think it brought greater joy into the world. And so I'm always in favor of greater joy. I think that's right. But there was also some backlash to this ad campaign.
这真的很有趣。就像我不知道，你看到这一切有什么感受？我觉得这很棒。这真的很像，你知道的，它利用了怀旧情绪，我对此总是有点紧张。但我认为它给世界带来了更大的快乐。所以我总是支持更多的快乐。我想是这样的。但这次广告活动也引起了一些反弹。
What could possibly make people mad about this ad campaign? So the main argument, this was coming from people who are working in food security. So this is largely from advocates who were saying, look, no frills is a discount brand. It's not really funny, right? Like, to them, the yellow and black packaging recalls, you know, scarcity recalls, times when you didn't have a lot of money. So for them, it kind of really clashed with the ironic embrace of the silliness of the packaging.
什么会让人对这次广告活动感到生气呢？所以主要的争论点，这是来自从事食品安全工作的人。所以这主要来自倡导者，他们说，看，无修饰是一个折扣品牌。这其实并不好笑，对吧？对他们来说，黄色和黑色的包装让人想起，你知道的，短缺，想起你没有太多钱的时期。所以对他们来说，这与对包装愚蠢之处的讽刺性拥抱确实发生了冲突。
I don't know if there's an inherent quality of making fun of the fact that it's discount in these things. So I don't know. And I guess the flip side of it is also that if you are taking this kind of ironic funny tone, maybe it takes away some of the stigma. If there is any stigma of buying like a discount grocery store. So I think on the whole like that at campaign is pretty good.
我不知道拿它是折扣这件事开玩笑是不是有一种内在的品质。所以我不确定。我想它的另一面也是，如果你采取这种讽刺搞笑的基调，也许它会消除一些污名。如果购买折扣杂货店有什么污名的话。所以我觉得总体而言，那个广告活动相当不错。
Yeah, yeah. I agree. So this kind of brings us to the second news item about Canadian grocery stores. So this one is actually about the parent company of No Forels and Pop Quiz. You remember the name of the parent company NoFrills. I do love laws. It is love laws. So, lawbloss has been getting a lot of bad press recently and part of that is because, of course, COVID-19 has made all of these people who work at grocery stores front-line workers.
是的，是的。我同意。所以这把我们带到了关于加拿大杂货店的第二个新闻。所以这个实际上是关于无修饰和 Pop Quiz 的母公司。你还记得母公司的名字吗，无修饰。我当然爱罗布劳斯。是罗布劳斯。所以，罗布劳斯最近得到了很多负面新闻，部分原因是，当然，COVID-19 使得所有这些在杂货店工作的人都成了前线工人。
Yeah, of course. Yeah. Of course. And at the beginning of the pandemic, law blas and lots of other companies announced that they were giving grocery store workers a raise of $2 an hour. It was basically hazard pay for people going in to their jobs who had to go in so that we had a food supply that was secure. Well, then in June, law blas announced that they had decided to end the hazard pay. What they were saying was that we can't afford
是的，当然。是的。当然。在大流行开始时，罗布劳斯和许多其他公司宣布，他们将给杂货店工人每小时加薪 2 美元。这基本上是给那些不得不去上班的人的危险津贴，他们必须去上班，以便我们拥有安全的食品供应。好吧，然后在 6 月份，罗布劳斯宣布他们决定取消危险津贴。他们说的是我们负担不起
to keep paying people at a higher rate. And a lot of people were mad about that partly because law bluffs earnings have gone up because more people are going to the grocery store during the pandemic. So that has been this big story. And as a result, there have actually been some workers who have been striking at supermarkets that are owned by law bluffs. It's well with the rights. It's absolutely like not any less dangerous than it was when this thing started. And so it makes total sense to me that they would keep their hazard pay to keep feeding
继续以更高的费率向人们支付工资。许多人对此感到愤怒，部分原因是罗布劳斯的收益上升了，因为在大流行期间去杂货店的人更多了。所以这是一个重大新闻。因此，实际上有一些工人在罗布劳斯拥有的超市进行了罢工。这关系到权利。这绝对不像这件事刚开始时那么安全。所以这对我来说完全合情合理，他们会保留危险津贴来继续养活
a nation, which is of critical importance. So I wish them the best of luck. Well, Roman, this brings us to the third news item about lawblas. It's also kind of a negative story about Loblaws, but I think you'll agree. It's quite a bit funnier. It's the great Canadian bread price fixing scandal. So obviously know about this, right? I must admit that I missed most of that.
一个国家，这是至关重要的。所以我祝他们好运。好吧，罗曼，这把我们带到了关于罗布劳斯的第三个新闻。这也是一个关于罗布劳斯的负面故事，但我认为你会同意，它要有趣得多。这就是伟大的加拿大面包价格操纵丑闻。所以显然你知道这个，对吧？我必须承认我错过了大部分内容。
This is kind of a complicated news item, but follow me here because there's a lot of twists and turns and it involves the American presidential election. Oh, okay. So Roman, do you know what price fixing is? a lot of twists and turns and it involves the American presidential election. Oh, okay. So Roman, do you know what price fixing is? It means basically different competitors are all agreeing on a price. They're flouting the market and making a higher price for consumers. It's illegal, right?
这是一个相当复杂的新闻，但请跟着我走，因为这里有很多曲折，而且它涉及美国总统大选。哦，好吧。所以罗曼你知道什么是价格操纵吗？有很多曲折，而且它涉及美国总统大选。哦，好吧。所以罗曼你知道什么是价格操纵吗？这意味着基本上不同的竞争对手都同意一个价格。他们在蔑视市场，为消费者制定更高的价格。这是非法的，对吧？
Like that's anti-competitive behavior. What happened in 2017 is that the competition Bureau of Canada announced that for 14 years, Canadian grocery stores had been teaming up to inflate the price of bread. So this was a big scandal. Loblaws admitted that they had a hand in this and they agreed that they had to make good. They were very sorry for what they had done. So they were going to give a $25 gift certificate to anybody who wanted it, who shopped at Loblaws. And that's it for 14 years of making people pay higher prices for bread. You got $25.
就像那是反竞争行为一样。2017 年发生的事情是，加拿大竞争局宣布，14 年来，加拿大杂货店一直在联手哄抬面包价格。所以这是一个大丑闻。罗布劳斯承认他们参与其中，并同意他们必须纠正错误。他们对自己的所作所为感到非常抱歉。所以他们要向任何想要的、在罗布劳斯购过物的人发放 25 加元的礼品券。这就是 14 年来让人支付更高面包价格的代价。你得到了 25 美元。
A lot of people obviously were very mad because they were like, wow, this seems like a huge scandal. So this was a big new story in Canada. A lot of people got their $25 gift cards and it died down. And then this year, the story came back up in the news. And that's because Pete Buttigieg ran for president. Okay, so please close the loop on this for me because I have no idea what you're talking about. This isn't logical for you, but...
许多人显然非常生气，因为他们觉得，哇，这看起来像是一个巨大的丑闻。所以这是加拿大的一大新闻。许多人拿到了他们的 25 加元礼品卡，然后这件事就平息了。然后今年，这个故事又出现在新闻中。那是因为皮特·布蒂吉格（Pete Buttigieg）竞选总统。好吧，请为我把这个闭环，因为我不知道你在说什么。这对我来说不合逻辑，但是……
Uh, so you remember Pete Buttigieg? Of course, I remember Pete Buttigieg. I had some affection for Pete Buttigieg, of course. Yeah, sure. Mara Soutman, Indiana, military veteran. Yeah. So, Mar Pete, when he was running, there was some criticism of one of his previous jobs, which was that he was a business consultant for McKinsey. So, McKinsey is one of these companies
嗯，所以你还记得皮特·布蒂吉格吗？当然，我记得皮特·布蒂吉格。我以前对皮特·布蒂吉格挺有好感的，当然。是的，没错。印第安纳州的玛拉·索特曼，退伍军人。是的。所以，玛·皮特，当他参选时，有人对他之前的一份工作提出了批评，那就是他曾是麦肯锡的商业顾问。所以，麦肯锡就是那种
that goes in, offers advice on how businesses can run more efficiently. And there's a lot of pressure on Mara Pete to divulge what work he had been doing for McKinsey. So, he gave out this list of like, here's all the clients that I consulted on for McKinsey. And one of them was take a wild guess. It was love laws. It was love laws. Yeah, hell yeah. Here is the actual wording of the press release
深入企业内部，为企业如何更高效地运营提供建议的公司。人们给玛·皮特施加了很大压力，要求他透露他为麦肯锡做过什么工作。于是，他公布了一份名单，上面写着：“这些是我为麦肯锡提供过咨询服务的客户。”其中一个嘛，你随便猜。那就是Loblaws超市。那是Loblaws超市。是的，太棒了。以下是新闻稿中的实际用词
that Mayor Pete put out. He said he was a consultant with love laws on the effects of price cuts on various combinations of items across hundreds of stores. Oh my goodness. So when this came out and people started piecing together the timeline, there were all these Canadians saying,
皮特市长发布的。他说他曾担任Loblaws的顾问，评估降价对数百家商店各种商品组合的影响。哦天哪。所以当这件事曝光，人们开始拼凑时间线时，许多加拿大人纷纷表示：
hey, wait a second, was Mayor Pete the reason that our bread costs so much money for years? Was he part of that? Lobla says no. And Mayor Pete's campaign said, we have no idea what you're talking about. What is this bread price scandal? But it became this controversy and he kept getting asked about it. In fact, when he was
“等等，皮特市长是不是我们面包多年来这么贵的罪魁祸首？他参与其中了吗？”Loblaws说没有。皮特市长的竞选团队则表示，我们不知道你在说什么。这是什么面包价格丑闻？但这成了一场争议，他不断被问及此事。事实上，当他在
doing his big interview with the New York Times editorial board, it was one of the big questions. So I have sent you this video link. Have you seen this video before? I have not seen it. So let me watch it. So let's let's play it. You've been on the front lines of corporate downs it. You've been on the front lines of corporate downsizing. You've been on the front lines of corporate price fixing. You've been on the front lines of our misadventures of our misadventures in foreign policy. You've had direct experience of many of the things
接受《纽约时报》编辑委员会的重要采访时，这也是核心问题之一。所以我已经把这个视频链接发给你了。你以前看过这个视频吗？我没看过。那让我看看吧。那我们播放一下吧。你曾身处企业裁员的最前线。你曾身处企业裁员的最前线。你曾身处企业价格操纵的最前线。你曾身处我们外交政策失误的最前线。你曾身处我们外交政策失误的最前线。你亲身经历过许多事情
that make a lot of young people very angry about the way that this country is operating right now. You don't seem to embody that anger. So the proposition that I've been on frontlines of corporate price fixing is, just to get that out of the way. You worked for a company that was fixing bread prices? No, I worked for a consulting company
让许多年轻人对这个国家目前的运作方式感到非常愤怒。你似乎并没有体现出这种愤怒。那么，“我曾身处企业价格操纵最前线”这种说法——为了撇清这一点——你曾在一家操纵面包价格的公司工作过？不，我曾在一家咨询公司工作过
that had a client that may have been involved in fixing or was apparently in a scandal. I was not aware of the Canadian bread pricing scandal until last night. Wow, that's quite a scandal. I was not aware of the Canadian bread pricing scandal until last night. Wow, that's quite a moment. Yeah. Yeah. So it was published in the New York Times this whole exchange about the bread price fixing scandal. And it was probably the most emotion Mayor Pete showed on the campaign trail. And I have no evidence that the great Canadian bread price fixing scandal torpedoed his candidacy, but I mean, that didn't help. That wasn't a good moment in his campaign.
该公司的一个客户可能卷入了价格操纵，或者显然卷入了一场丑闻。直到昨晚，我才知道加拿大的面包定价丑闻。哇，这真是一场大丑闻。直到昨晚，我才知道加拿大的面包定价丑闻。哇，这真是个戏剧性的时刻。是啊。是啊。所以《纽约时报》发表了这段关于面包价格操纵丑闻的对话。这可能是皮特市长在竞选活动中表现出的最多情绪了。我没有证据表明伟大的加拿大面包价格操纵丑闻摧毁了他的参选资格，但我的意思是，这确实没有帮助。那不是他竞选期间的高光时刻。
That's amazing that it had such a huge effect. And what a bizarre footnote to this story of law, blossom bread. I know. And hey, look, I know a couple months ago, and I pitched, I want to do this story about Canadian grocery stores that maybe there wasn't the intrigue of other things you done the show. But I mean, I think with all of these news items, what you see is that grocery stores are mundane, they're very everyday, but they also affect us.
真不敢相信它会有这么大的影响。对Loblaws和面包这个故事来说，这真是一个离奇的注脚。我懂。嘿，听着，几个月前我提出想做一个关于加拿大杂货店的故事时，它可能没有你节目里其他内容的那些阴谋诡异感。但我的意思是，我觉得通过所有这些新闻，你会发现杂货店很平凡，它们非常日常，但它们也影响着我们。
Like the thing with everyday things is they really have an impact on our lives. There's so much of people's lives that are tied to these grocery stores, even though we kind of take them for granted, there's just so much going on there. Yeah. Oh, just for the record, I was always sold on this. I know you were sold. I feel like though, tell like other people I'm doing a story about Canadian grocery stores might not have been
就像日常事物一样，它们确实对我们的生活产生了影响。人们的生活中有很大一部分与这些杂货店息息相关，尽管我们有点认为它们理所当然，但那里发生的事情实在是太多了。是的。哦，顺便说一句，我一直对这个选题很感兴趣。我知道你很感兴趣。不过我觉得，如果去告诉别人我在做一个关于加拿大杂货店的故事，可能不会
the bombshell dynamite pitch. I mean, I think the fact that the pitch included a clip of repo man was enough for me to a green light it. So I really appreciate it Chris, thanks so much. Absolutely, everybody go watch repo man. Thanks, Roman. 99% invisible was produced this week by Chris Barube, Music by Sean Riel, Sound Mix by Sarah McCarthy. Special thanks this week to Linda Burbank, the YouTube channel Retro Ontario, the archival
是一个充满爆点和震撼力的选题。我的意思是，我觉得这个选题里包含了电影《盘丝洞》（Repo Man）的一个片段，对我来说就足够批准它通过了。所以非常感谢你，克里斯，太感谢了。绝对的，大家快去去看《盘丝洞》。谢谢你，罗曼。《99%隐形》本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，肖恩·里尔配乐，萨拉·麦卡锡混音。特别感谢琳达·伯班克、YouTube频道“安大略复古”、CBC广播电台的档案
team at CBC Radio, and the late great journalist Anne Kingston. And thanks to Terrio Riley, whose newest podcast is called, We Regret to Inform You. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Abby Madon, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco
团队，以及已故伟大的记者安·金斯顿。还要感谢特里奥·里利，他的最新播客节目叫《我们遗憾地通知您》。我们的资深制作人是德兰尼·霍尔。库尔特·科尔斯蒂德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·勒、艾比·马顿、凯蒂·明格尔、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 电台的一个项目
and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered across the North American continent but will always be in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. We have all kinds of new merch in the 99PI store, including a Mabyee masks and t-shirts
并在无线电排屋（Radio Row）制作，该排屋散布在北美大陆，但将永远位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的独立播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解详情。你可以在 Twitter 上@RomanMars，在节目上@99PI org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。我们在 99PI 商店里有各种各样的周边商品，包括 Mabyee 口罩和印有缆车图案的 T 恤
with finiculars on them. Plus links to purchase the brand new book. It's called the 99% Invisible City. It's out October 6th. All that. And more at 9i9pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX.
以及购买全新书本的链接。书名叫《99%隐形城市》。将于10月6日出版。所有这些以及更多内容尽在 99pi.org。Radio Topia 出品，来自 PRX。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。该集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。